we already know that the sum of the
interior angles of a triangle add up to
180 degrees so if the measure of this
angle is a the measure of this angle
over here is b and the measure of this
angle is c we know that a plus b plus c
is equal to 180 degrees but what happens
when we have polygons with more than
three sides so let's try the case where
we have a four-sided polygon a
quadrilateral and i'm going to make it
irregular just to show that whatever we
do here probably if it applies to any
quadrilateral with four sides not just
things that have right angles and
parallel lines and all the rest actually
that looks a little bit too close to
being parallel so let me draw it like
this
let me draw it like this
so the way you can think about it with a
four-sided quadrilateral as well we
already know about this the interior the
measures of the interior angles of a
triangle at up to 180 so maybe we can
divide this into two triangles so we
from this point right over here if we
draw a line like this
if we draw a line like this we've
divided it into two triangles and so if
the measure of this angle is a measure
of this is b measure of that is c we
know that a
plus b plus c is equal to 180 degrees
and then if we call this over here x
this over here y and that z those are
the measures of those angles we know
that x plus y
plus z is equal to 180 degrees and so if
we want the measure of the sum of all of
the interior angles that's going to be
all the interior angles are going to be
b
plus
z
that's two of the interior angles of
this polygon plus
this angle which is just going to be a
plus x
plus a plus x a plus x is that whole
angle the whole angle for the
quadrilateral
plus this whole angle which is going to
be c plus y
c
plus y and we already know a plus b plus
c is 180 degrees a plus b plus c
is 180 degrees and we know that z
plus x plus y is equal to 180 degrees so
plus 180 degrees which is equal to 360
degrees so i think you see the general
idea here we just have to figure out how
many triangles we can divide something
into and then we just take we just
multiply by 180 degrees since each of
those triangles will have 180 degrees
let's do one more particular example and
then we'll try to do a general a general
version we're just trying to figure out
how many triangles can we fit into that
thing so let me draw an irregular
pentagon so one two
three
four
five so it looks like a little bit of a
sideways house there
once again we can draw our triangles
inside of this pentagon so that would be
one triangle there that would be another
triangle so i'm able to draw three
non-overlapping triangles that that
perfectly cover this pentagon this is
one triangle the other penta the other
triangle and the other one and we know
each of those will have 180 degrees if
we take the sum of their angles and we
also know the sum of all of those
interior angles are equal to the sum of
the interior angles of the polygon as a
whole and to see that clearly this
interior angle is one of the angles of
the polygon this is as well but when you
take the sum of this one and this one
then you're going to get that whole
interior angle of the polygon when you
take the sum of that one and that one
you get that entire one and then when
you take the sum of that one plus that
one plus that one you get that entire
interior angle so if you take the sum of
all of the interior angles of all of
these triangles you're actually just
finding the sum of all of the interior
angles of the polygon so in this case
you have one two three triangles so
three times 180 degrees is equal to what
300 plus 240 is equal to 540 degrees now
let's generalize it and to generalize it
let's realize that just to get just to
get our first two triangles we have to
use up four sides we have to use up all
the four sides in this quadrilateral we
had to use up four we had to use up four
of the five sides right here in this
pentagon one two and then three four so
four sides give you two give you two
triangles and it seems like maybe every
incremental side you have after that you
can get another triangle out of it let's
experiment with a hexagon and i'm just
going to try to see how many triangles i
get out of it so one
two three
four
five six sides
six sides and i can get one triangle
i get one triangle out of these two
sides one two sides of the actual
hexagon i can get another triangle out
of these two sides
of the actual hexagon and it looks like
i can get another triangle out of each
of the remaining sides so one out of
that one and then one out of that one
right over there so in general it seems
like it seems like let's say so let's
say that i have s sides
s sides
s sided polygon
s sided
polygon
and i'll just assume we already saw the
case for five sides or four sides five
sides or six sides so we can assume that
s is greater than four sides let's say i
have an s sided polygon and i want to
figure out how many triangles
non-overlapping triangles that perfectly
cover that polygon how many can i fit
inside of it and then i just have to
multiply the number of triangles times
180 degrees to figure out what are the
the sum of the interior angles of that
polygon so let's figure out the number
of triangles as a function as a function
of the number of sides
so once again two of the sides or four
of the sides are going to be used to
make two triangles so those two sides
right over there and then we have two
sides right over there
i can have i can draw one triangle over
and i'm not even going to talk about
what happens on the other the rest of
the sides of the polygon you can imagine
putting a big black piece of
construction paper there might be other
sides here i'm not going to worry about
them right now so out of these two sides
i can draw one triangle just like that
out of these two sides i can draw
another triangle right over there so
four sides
used
for two triangles two triangles
and then
no matter how many sides i have left
over so i've already used four of the
sides but after that if i have all sorts
of craziness here i could have all sorts
of craziness here so let me draw it a
little bit neater than that
so i can have all sorts of craziness
all sorts of craziness right over here
it looks like every other incremental
side i can get another triangle out of
it so that's one triangle out of there
one triangle out of that side one
triangle out of that side one triangle
out of that side and then one triangle
out of this side so for example this
figure that i've drawn is a very
irregular 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 ten is that right one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
it is a decagon and i in this decagon
four of the sides were used for two
triangles so i got two triangles out of
four of the sides and of the other six
sides i was able to get a triangle each
these are six there's one two three four
five actually let me make sure i'm
counting the number of sides right so i
have
one
two
three
10. so let me make sure did i count
am i am i just not seeing something
oh i see i actually didn't i have to
draw another line right over here these
are two different sides let's have to
draw another line right over here i can
get another triangle out of that right
over there and so there you have it i
have these two triangles out of four
sides and then out of the other six
remaining sides i get a triangle each so
plus six triangles i got a total of
eight triangles and so we can general
generally think about it the first four
sides the first four sides we're going
to get two triangles we're going to get
two triangles so let me write this down
so our number of triangles number of
triangles is going to be equal to 2
and then i've already used four sides so
the remaining sides i get a triangle
each so the remaining sides are going to
be s minus 4. so the number of triangles
are going to be 2 plus s minus 4. 2 plus
s minus 4 is just s
minus 2. so if i have an s sided polygon
and if i have an s sided polygon i can
get s minus 2 triangles that perfectly
cover that polygon and they don't
overlap with each other which tells us
that an s sided polygon if it has s
minus two triangles that the interior
angles in it are going to be s minus two
times 180 degrees which is a pretty cool
result so if someone told you that they
had 102 sided polygon 102 sides so s is
equal to 102 sides you can say okay the
number of interior angles are going to
be 102 minus 2 so it's going to be 100
times 180 degrees which is equal to 180
with two more zeros behind it so it'd be
18 000 degrees for the interior angles
of 102 two-sided polygon